Dude,
I don't know how you do this.
You're so friendly too.
So easy going live.
You see so peaceful.
Like you don't seem like a shell shocked guy,
you know,
you really don't.
You seem very,
very even [inaudible].
That's good to hear that six months ago the Amanda be,
yeah,
I mean I think I still have PTSD,
but it definitely helped.
And I bumped into a friend of mine that the Diet Dan [inaudible] who made the
Michael Jackson documentary,
I saw him in New York a few weeks.
Neverland.
Dr Yeah.
When you said Ben,
you just seem,
you just seem a bit a bit calmer.
What,
what is your take on that documentary?
I have not watched it,
but I've heard that those two guys at testified saying that nothing had ever
happened to them before this.
And then,
then now they're down on their lock and now they've changed their tune and
saying that it was,
they,
they go into that in detail in the dock and uh,
basically they'd been replaced by the new young boy up to the side.
And then Michael reached out and said,
I need you to help me.
And they say it was exciting,
the idea to be,
to be back in Michael's good books and be wanted by Michael again.
So they,
they,
they talk about that very openly.
I had dinner with him a week before the film came out and I believe them
railing.
Yeah.
And one of them certainly I think has,
has what looks like the symptoms of Ptsd.
And the other one I think went through therapy before he was able to talk about
this stuff.
So I don't think that doing it for financial gain.
What did you think about the Dr. Michael Jackson's doctor saying that he was
chemically castrated?
Oh,
I didn't,
I didn't hear that in the near them.
This is something that we've talked about before because his voice was so
different.
And to me,
I said a long time ago before his doctor came out and said he was chemically
castrate.
I said,
these sounds like Castrato.
He sounds like one of those men who are taken as boys and you know,
the 18 hundreds and the 17 chose to do it.
The doctor say,
I don't know.
I think the doctor is saying that his father did it to them.
I think that was with,
this is the doctor that killed her mother.
Right.
So take that with a grain of salt.
But they were saying that he chemically crass treated him to preserve as voice.
Which,
you know,
it sounds preposterous until you look at his frame.
I mean,
it did not have the frame of a person who had just kissed her on the same kids
you did.
Some of those kids he's getting on as kids,
they're definitely not as kids.
I mean,
so we're talking to her about how it's easy to get the facts to fit a theory,
you know?
But those kids are not his kids.
Those are the whitest kids you're ever going to look at it.
Yeah,
they're really white.
I mean,
they're not part African American.
and he,
we got to remember before is vital.
I ego kicked in,
he was very dark.
You know,
he looked like his brothers.
Yeah.
It looks like his father.
I mean it's,
um,
I dunno,
I hadn't had that theory before that his kids,
his kids,
when these kids really haven't had many theories,
I'm not,
I didn't think that much about Michael Jackson.
So I mean,
I think that's just been pretty much established.
Yeah.
That his kids weren't really as kids.
And I think is the woman that he had children with,
I think was all on the record saying they never had sex.
Like I think,
I think they,
I think they talk about that as well.
Yeah.
I Dunno,
but it's,
it,
when we,
we had a similar case in the UK with Jimmy Savile at the most popular or that's,
that seems even worse.
And the documentary is great because it's a portrait of how you grew up,
not just the kid,
but the family as well.
And in some ways you groom the entire country to the point where if accusations
come out,
everyone says,
no,
not him.
No Way.
Right.
That's,
that's how it works.
Or he looked like a monster.
Yeah.
Michael Jackson looked like a monster eventually,
but when we always go back to him as a boy when he was seeing an ABC,
I mean he was just adorable little kid,
incredibly talented and so dynamic and exciting to watch.
Like God,
he's so talented.
Look at him.
And then in thriller,
I mean everybody loved him,
but Jimmy Savile looks like a monster in retrospect.
I wrote to him as a kid because he had a show called Demo,
fix it.
Right.
We had grant you your wish and then you'd sit on his lap and he'd give you a
medal.
You got off light.
No,
no one thought he was a monster back then.
No one.
But he was so hideous.
Yeah.
And,
and uh,
Louis through did a great documentary with them.
He keeps his mother's bedroom.
Exactly.
Was,
it was all the clothes hanging in the closet.
Yeah.
But honestly,
in his lifetime,
this was not discussed but not questioned.
Yeah.
And like I say,
I think he groomed the entire country.
Well,
there's so many cases like that where you have this systemic pedophile situation
that doesn't make sense.
Like,
how did this,
how did this last,
like Penn state,
like the Sandusky case,
like how did this,
how did,
everyone seems to have known about it.
How did it last and people had seen a kid in the shower and hadn't,
I mean,
yeah,
you think now you'd,
you'd,
you'd kill yourself if you didn't intervene in some way.
I think it's also easy to forget how much that wasn't part of the conversations
back then though.
You know,
the idea that there are pedophiles out there and it's actually incredibly
widespread.
That just wasn't right.
That wasn't something people were worried about back then from my memory,
at least anyway.
No,
it was church who was Catholic Church priests.
We knew about that every other than that,
but there was no discussion of like some world famous football coach was
secretly fucking kids like that.
You never heard that.
I mean,
and paternal,
they think [inaudible] had to have known.
There's no way he couldn't have known or at least been exposed to some of it and
to the conversation we had earlier.
I remember that great documentary where a guide protest in front of the statue
and another guy comes up and tries to beat him up just for daring to suggest
that,
you know,
this,
this hero of his would be capable of that.
People just,
you know,
they just can't fathom it because they've been so well groomed,
but also Penn state football was just sucks.
It's a religion.
It's so important to them and to,
to see that these people that were in charge of it,
we're so fucked up,
man.
Jesus man's shows a bummer.
Sorry about that.